blood vessels of the human body. Their surface area is 700,000 square meters. They measure more
than a hundred thousand kilometers in length. That's seven times the diameter of the globe.
Every day, the heart beats a hundred thousand times to keep blood circulating through these
arteries and veins. Blood is the very stuff of life. One cubic millimeter of liquid blood plasma
contains five million red corpuscles
and 700,000 phagocytes, or white.
They're the policemen of the bloodstream,
always on the lookout for germs.
Just a moment, quick, after them, officer.
To answer!
Any problems, Lieutenant?
The lymphocyte patrol will always help the police in an emergency.
For the moment, all's well in this sector,
despite the heavy traffic flow of busy red corpuscles loaded with gas.
Grandpa, can't you walk any faster?
Young lady, I can see you've got no respect for your elders. Too bad.
Sorry. Look here, Hemo, you don't seem to be your usual bright self today.
Well, you know how much I hate it when I've got an enormous load of carbon dioxide to deliver?
It brings me out in a sweat and I can't catch my breath.
It wouldn't bother me. What's this?
I'd rather carry oxygen any day. At least, you know, it's pure.
Come on, big fellow, cheer up, hmm? It's not far to the lungs now.
A policeman must sacrifice his own life to keep the bloodstream safe for others.
I didn't know he was dangerous.
You'll learn soon enough, my dear.
Never trust a stranger.
Outsiders are dangerous.
Luckily, our police are always on the alert.
Come on, the show's over.
Move along there.
Get moving.
It's along there.
Hey, working in the lungs.
It won't be long now, Hemo.
We'll soon be out in the lovely fresh air and you'll get your oxygen.
No end.
Yes, and it's unbelievably boring to march around the same old route 4,000 times a day.
I'm quite happy to do it 365 days a year.
65 days, a very long lifespan for corpuscles like us.
I hate to disillusion you, but our lives are much shorter, believe me.
A short life and a merry one, that's what I say.
Hey, you. Move along there.
I'm so sorry, officer. I didn't realize that you'd notice me.
Calling all sales, calling all sales.
Sugar in short supply, sugar in short supply.
Please release your reserves immediately.
Oh, was that my fault?
But of course not, my dear.
It's a general shortage in the whole sector.
Calling all cells make your reserve sugar available immediately.
Young people of today, no thought for the future, no organization, whatever.
Why, in my day, thought ahead.
Calling sugar stores, calling sugar stores, release some sugar immediately.
Here control room, a signal goes out to the part of the cell where sugar is stored.
The Golgai bodies.
When the signal is received, sugar is released through the walls of the cell.
Soon the shortage will be over.
Better say goodbye to you now. I'm afraid that my journey through life is over.
But there's no reason to feel sad. We all live for 100 days, 120 at the outside.
And we do live a full life. Then we go to rest in the spleen.
I suppose you'll be coming along with me this time.
Me too. And me as well.
You're going to become of us after you've gone away. Two of us just can't cope with all that work on our own.
Do you know how quickly we are reborn? Over two million of us per second.
A million red corpuscles born per second?
Oh, but, Father dear, we really will miss you very much indeed.
Whatever will we do without your good advice?
Thank you, but I'll be back.
I promise.
Bye for now.
Bye.
In bloodstream, rate of breathing has been increased.
Report to your nearest cell on the double.
That's yours.
But never mind, Globin dear, it's not far now.
Go get him.
You want to report, Lieutenant?
...is like you get on my nerves.
Idle.
That's what you are, idle.
What have we here?
Your job is to carry gases from one part of the body to another.
So get on with it then.
Yes, sir.
I've got more than a full load on my back already.
We're not slaves, are we?
We'll just have to take on more workers.
They'll just have to work much faster, Lieutenant.
Uh, um, that's not going to work.
We'll use another method instead.
Send in the macrophage units.
That seems to have cleared up the blockage.
Now let's get those red corpuscles moving.
Come on.
All right, let's go.
Uh-oh.
That's all we need.
Possible invasion. Please send patrol urgently.
Calling all units.
Investigate suspected alien invaders without delay.
Repeat. Investigate suspected alien invaders.
Just a second.
I hope you have no objections, sir.
But I must ask for your identity card.
It's just to prove that you don't come from outside the body.
Invasion, send reinforcements!
But it was nothing out of the ordinary, sir.
These streptococci are all in a day's work around here.
Send in sanitation squad immediately.
Operation successfully concluded.
Everybody, the show's over. Let's get moving.
On your way, Corpuscles.
Bye, Lieutenant. Take care, Captain.
It is sneezing.
Well, it seems that some of the white corpuscle policemen in his body are asleep on duty.
Exhausted by their recent battle.
This very moment, a small party of viruses appear.
We're nearly there, man. Come on.
We're creeping while they guard us down.
Surprise attack is finally noticed by a swarm of tiny antibodies.
Just swat them and keep going.
The nuclear control room of the cell, all is calm.
Too calm, perhaps.
Hang on here, for goodness sake, we're under attack.
Cell number 4714 reporting.
We're under heavy attack by type B flu viruses.
Please pass on the information.
Right away, right away.
But who's this now?
That's it.
I'm calling a general alert for all the cells in the 4,000 sector.
Calling all cells, general alert.
We're under attack by type B flu virus.
All antibody defenders to their stations immediately.
Hello, police.
Come in, police.
This is an emergency.
Oh, why can't I get through when I need them urgently?
Calling police patrol.
To sanitation squad, hello?
Hello?
Attachment of macrophages to junction number seven, please.
Get an important job to do.
I don't agree, you know.
I think you do a very important task.
For example, a minute ago you helped to clear the circulation.
Yes, it wasn't essential.
That may be so, but there are other tasks that come.
When we will be lost without you, platelets, you'll see.
Platelets.
Calling police patrol.
Come in, police patrol.
Why can't I contact you when I need you most?
Come in, patrol.
Lieutenant Claire of the patrol squad at your service.
At last, not before time.
You're never there when you're needed, are you?
This is cell number 4715.
We've got a viral invasion in our sector.
Hurry.
This is Captain Peter speaking.
We are now on our way.
Take over a cell and start multiplying inside it.
Precisely.
Now, are you going to hang about till it's my turn?
Can't you see how serious the situation is?
We don't have a moment to lose.
Lieutenant Jumbo, take your ground forces to within striking distance of the enemy.
Wait for my signal to attack.
The lymphocyte ship squadron will provide air cover, take up position, and wait for my order to commence antibody bombardment.
Lieutenant Clare, we'll stay here in reserve with the lasers. Send a signal to General Headquarters.
All right now, men. Polynuclear infantry, up an atom, and show these aliens no mercy.
Yes, sir. They type B flu viruses.
Evidently, sir. We've dealt with them before, and we feel confident that we can handle them now. We've been vaccinated.
Well, carry on, Captain Peter, and good luck.
All right now, Lieutenant. I want you to defend the healthy cells. That's the only way we'll stop the virus multiplying.
Very good, Captain. I understand.
Calling commanders of antibody units, confirm your combat-ready status and prepare to drop into battle zone objective to defend cells against viral attack.
Metro, are your men ready?
Ready? You must be joking.
There's a question. You know very well that my splendid body of men has been spoiling for a fight ever since it was formed.
That's enough of that, Metro. There's no time for boasting now.
What I want from you is a straight answer to a straight question. Is that clear?
I'm sending you down there to protect cells. Are you equipped to deal with the enemy?
Yes, we're trained and vaccinated.
Let's go then.
Follow me, men. Let's jump.
We're promised.
Situation report, Lieutenant.
Yes, sir. We are engaging the enemy and blocking their advance, but they're not beaten yet, I'm afraid.
Yes, Lieutenant Claire.
My antibody troops can't contain them, sir. They multiply far too rapidly. We need reinforcements as soon as possible.
I'm afraid we'll have to cope on our own, Lieutenant.
General headquarters entrusted us with this mission and we cannot let them down.
After all, it's only a regional conflict.
I'm sure that we have the resources to handle it.
Now, here's what our next move will be.
I'm going to order a cell division maneuver.
General cell division, then artillery support.
Calling all corpuscle ground forces.
You're ordered to execute a strategic withdrawal immediately.
Bind ground and air forces.
Calling all white corpuscles and lymphocytes.
Prepare to carry out Operation Mitosis.
Wait for my order.
Ready, divide!
Heat the maneuver as soon as you're ready.
Toxic lasers at will.
Take careful aim men, we don't want to harm our sight.
Sad, there's no point in getting all upset, especially over a white corpuscle.
I've had a pretty good innings for a corpuscle, I suppose. About time I was recycled.
That's it, all the excitement's over for now. Move along there. Move along!